americans are likely to see much higher
heating bills this winter oh boy nearly
half of all u.s households mostly use
natural gas to eat their homes those
families could pay 30 percent more and
that would raise their heating costs to
about 175
to 746 that's a lot a year ago the
prices were lower because of this
pandemic
and a warner and warmer than average
winter and i came to you too soon our
consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner there she is has been
looking into this anna warner good
morning to you
good morning to you gail yeah so the
experts tell us is the bad news is
demand is driving those price increases
for natural gas propane and electricity
and that has some people already looking
for ways to conserve
to save money the knight family in new
york bought a wi-fi thermostat they can
control from their phone we upgraded and
we got a condensing boiler and i
definitely noticed that the gas bills
are lower the u.s energy information
administration forecasts all major home
heating bills will increase
significantly because of higher fuel
costs and potentially colder weather
this winter for the nearly half of u.s
households who heat with natural gas the
cost is expected to rise 30 percent this
year the 5 who use propane and the 4
percent who primarily use heating oil
will likely see their costs go up 54
more and 43 percent more for the roughly
40 percent of u.s households who use
electricity prices are expected to
increase just a bit about 6 percent
we've seen a very large increase in both
natural gas and oil prices halima croft
is the managing director at rbc capital
markets so what's behind the increase in
the oil and gas prices we've had this
global reopening from the pandemic which
has driven up demand for both natural
gas and oil energy companies have cut
back on investment in production because
of the pandemic and are now struggling
to keep up with demand you've had
historically low stockpiles for natural
gas and their real concerns about is
there enough global supply to meet
demand if you have a cold winter for
natural gas
so crop says even if it's a mild winter
you can still expect to pay more because
simply put energy prices have gone up
she says if the winter is a lot colder
globally that europe and asia could
actually be facing an energy crisis
scale
well then i got to say my heating unit
broke over the weekend so it was very
low
i felt like a human popsicle that's one
way you can save money just keep it
turned down but if you don't want to do
that what's another way that you can
save costs during this time
okay i'm really sorry to hear that you
know because that is a really hard thing
when you lose it was not for anybody wow
okay
well so and of course if you're doing it
intentionally um if you lower your
thermostat obviously that's a way to go
um the estimate is that you can save
about two percent off your heating bill
for each degree that you lower
your thermostat temperature also some of
the companies energy companies will give
you rebates if you do certain things to
help
with your energy consumption and of
course you can also look at cleaning
your furnace replacing filters for your
furnace and your heat pump all those are
good things to do
okay that's what i did place the filters
thank you very much anna appreciate that